目前是在一个国企，然后办公室负责干党建工作，然后嗯断断续续，嗯，就是超过两年的对象。我可能谈过有两个，然后今年的五月份五月底，然后家里给我介绍了一个男生，然后还有现在长相啊，外表各方面就是我还挺喜欢的。然后我后来慢慢的跟他接触的过程当中，嗯，我今年33，然后那个男生比我大一岁，今年是34。
嗯，然后我感觉他嗯人缘挺好的。嗯，我就跟他交往了3个月啊，5月底认识。然后到昨天晚上，我给他就反正就是各种说说完以后，我就嗯，可能是之前我心里就已经有这个想法。然后我就说了分手，就是你说他对我特别好吧，反正就是正常谈对象就是每天吃啊喝呀，问我的这种都问，然后也会就是每天给我点外卖，但是除此以外，别的事情我好像也没有太大的感受。我之前一一直在考虑，在纠结，我就说这个男生到底喜不喜欢，然后适不适合结婚呀，啥因为这个年龄在这儿，然后双方的家里人都就想着，如果说尽可能的话，就让我们今年年底就考虑去结婚。但是我昨天还是说了分手，然后我是在，嗯。
在那个，我是在甘肃这边的省会，他是在老家的县城。我毕业以后，然后就进了现在这个单位，就一直工作至今。然后他毕业以后比我晚，他可能是复读过比我晚两年吧。毕业以后，他就回小县城里，然后就在家里盖个房子。老家有一个自院啊，就是老宅子，他就他就负责盖起来。盖起来以后，他目前的收入就是老宅老宅子租出去的那个租金，大概有嗯，5000块钱左右一个月，但是毕业完以后回去，嗯，没工作一直。
然后，他有3个姐姐，他的3个姐姐，一个是他在国外定居了，还有一个是在，还有两个都是在外省。
然后听着，姐姐们的生活都还不错，但都是姐姐们，也都是全职。
然后，他也是这样的，就是我跟他在接触过程当中，我觉得他虽然没工作，但是生活上还是比较自律。
然后也对自己也是就是有时候也会去打麻将呀喝酒。但是他晚上也不能回家，不会太晚。你就感觉他的这个虽然没工作，但对自己的这个平时也不是一个就是胡作非为的这么一个人。
但是我后面跟他在接触的时候，我就感觉他好像对生活也没有什么追求，也没有什么情调。我试图去跟他沟通，我说，嗯，你要不要考虑去找一份工作或者自己创业干点啥？然后他说他不适合去给别人打工，然后他也没有计划说是去外面再找工作。
嗯，就是在找工作这件事情上，我可能感觉嗯，我短暂的我也许是因为喜欢我能接受，但是长期以往去生活，我可能不太能接受。就是你每个月收个三五千的租子钱，我觉得也可能因为现在大的环境不好，也许他收租子比我自个儿上班要稳定一点，但是我还是不太能接受。嗯，男生收租子，然后勤俭持家，他在家里就是特别的勤俭持家，然后家里面大大小小小到洗衣液洗衣粉都是她去采购，然后大到家里的装修呀，然后盖房子呀，都是她去操心。但是我总感觉我好像就坚持3个月下来，我不是很喜欢男生，就是在家里围在家里去收拾家家里这样的，所以就反正心里各种不舒服，但是我我就在想，是不是因为我的要求有点高，或者我想要的太多，所以？
嗯，谁给你介绍对象啊？谁给你介绍一个没有上进心的、不工作的这么一个对象？
对他对挣钱，还有对工作对事业这一方面，他他没有啥想法，他就觉得人嘛，就是活一天过一天，要及时行乐，就是我反正有收入，我也我也能自给自足。嗯，我说实话啊，如果说你俩不生小孩，就你俩就这么吃一个月，他收个三千五千的租金，你再挣个三千五千的，你俩这日子还能往下过。一旦将来要养小孩，那真的必须，爸爸妈妈必须得有上进心，必须得叫什么努力奔着，怎么能够多挣点钱，这日子才好过。
那你想要小孩吗？嗯，他我之前跟他有聊过，就是哎什么时候结婚，什么时候要小孩啊啥的。然后他就嗯，他他就他还是想要两个。然后我就觉得我的身体啊，以及我的工作各方面，我说我的极限能能接受一个都不错了。然后我跟他在聊天的过程当中，反正他没在家里吃过饭，我在想，是不是他母亲可能身体不太好，或者说是也不是一个特别会做饭的人。他一直是我在跟他聊的这几个月过程当中，他一直是在外面买着吃饭。然后他以后大概率和我会生活在城市里。嗯，但是。
我感觉他父母应该是不会上来，然后他爸爸有些兴趣和爱好。然后他爸爸每天就是早出晚归，有自己的朋友圈，然后养养着几百号鸽子，然后也有自己的这个养殖的这种小兴趣爱好。我很好奇的啊，嗯，如果他爸爸这个原件都是属于那种得过且过，能活一天是一天，不工作不上进，不过好日子的你，寄希望于他将来生出来的复印件是什么样的呢？
我在我在跟他接触的时候，我就感觉他的家庭就是嗯，就都是大家各过各的，他妈妈过他妈妈自己，然后他爸爸就照顾他爸爸自己的这个兴趣爱好小动物，然后过自己的就是这样的。但是唯一我我我我是考虑和他接触这三个月，是因为他的父母之前嗯在单位也是参加过工作，一个月也有3000来块钱的退休，是他父母能够自给自足，然后没有什么其他的压力，就他一个，所以我就跟他聊。但但是在聊的过程当中，我又感觉好像有些大大小小的事情，好像是我心里面不太能接受的。
你这个状态肯定是不太好的，我我我可能也是劳碌命啊，就是无非是劳碌命。我觉得人他总得有点事干，他那个才有精气神儿，活着才有那个热乎劲儿。如果一个人整天啥事儿也不想干，啥前程也不想问他，慢慢慢慢就枯萎了，那个生命的状态，而你跟一个枯萎的生命状态的人在一起的话，你自己要么就越来越暴躁，要么就越来越暴躁，要么就跟他一起枯萎。我的话就只能点到这儿了啊，不能多说了啊，好不好？嗯，我之前跟他在聊的时候，我就我就这样说，我说我想要找一个就是你跟我们一起去外面工作，然后一起去打拼，我们可以聊事业，聊工作回来以后，你可以照顾我，我也可以照顾你这样的，我说你在外面不去工作，然后你又很操持家里。我说那要我干什么呢？总不是让我去外面打拼。哎，反正就是考虑到他有些确实没有啥太大的负担，然后我就跟他接触。但是接触完以后，我又觉得这间的小细节好像又又挺消耗我又挺磨灭我，我就有点有所动摇，我就在想，是不是我有点激励吧？我就感觉食之无味，去实可惜的感觉。你回头也来评论区找答案吧。评论区他那些过来人，那些结过婚的姐姐们，怎么说这段关系吧？我跟你们就认真聊啊，两个人在一起啊，要想要感情持续啊，很。
或者说，两个人感情能够走得下去，他一定要有相互欣赏的点。这大家能接受吗？就甭管你老公有什么其他的缺点，但他身上一定有某一些点让你会欣赏。他发自内心的觉得哎哟，那挺好，挺佩服他的那种感觉啊。她这段关系才能够长久。如果像她的那个男朋友，就纯属摆烂，纯属摆烂。如果他身上很难找到你欣赏他的一个点的话，这日子是走不下去的。